zere
that was a great
take a look at this Tatum is as fast as
you'll find that his position that satin
frontin makes that hot run payoffs super
pass here by Rho G laid it up perfectly
[Applause]
talking about extending this is above
that that's just a great play by Brandon
evening Newark he just sitting there
wasted delays dude he's in the long
shoot our rubber got picked on so we
finally got a tableau Rose here with the
steel bleats Taylor Koga sit bone up to
the three up on the board is Vicki
grapevine in England staying aggressive
take that 16 point lead before the
three-point shot by Hayward it's all it
takes and then a sweet runners let's see
what Brandon ends up catching the ball
may show it out of position couldn't get
there in time and the foul on Donovan
Mitchell hesitation spins pass inside
stolen by halyard his court steal of the
night hip observant Tatum
[Applause]
before the quarter is over doc watch is
it seven game at 18 right down the
middle again a change of direction goes
to a little bit of a high screen that
comes back yeah he just waved at Brandon
as he went [ __ ] smart right there that
is so good oh man that is sweet Marcus
smart doing things on a defensive end
loses it
there's the punch-out look at them over
to Kai Reed
this painting with that man not Alonzo
bug though it goes down the door he goes
up sometimes a little ball fake is all
it takes is in Ingram their little ball
fake Bren whoops Willie cauley-stein bit
[Music]
Tatom to the basket
Green enroll splits the defense elevates
glides to the rim and sends it down
[Applause]
anger of hit a three from the other side
can't hit it from this side see that's
good pass that plays it Brandon to hit
on Christian Thompson
[Music]
Jason nice move with the dribble hard to
the basket
it right here going into the inside out
there's the moon there's the chair
[Applause]
take another look Saturn ASCII was a
Tenten good job by Ingres pulling it
back out and I don't waste the
possession with the bad shot takes us a
little bit of maturity it builds a
little bit of confidence
strong finish it knocks down the jumper
Memphis goes up by two
Carrie kicks it out smart good ball
movement Horford straight away 300 jason
statham and children all in bed because
that was insane
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
with his job
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
they never will
[Music]
native spins to the basket gets too
here in the garden there's Tatum coming
up all the people trying to go to the
high side he trip Tatum eats all the way
to the bucket spinning around gorgeous
averaging over 27 points per game
Meritage in the spin cycle here comes a
help Elias sobah quarters Gordon Hayward
is checked into the game
Oh
Tatom just rips through drives it hard
goes up sends it home strong along to
Brianna's letsa nearly got to another
one here comes Ambrose
[Applause]
he has been dynamic in the face of one
of the best shot blockers with Lopez you
don't want any part of this tato
that's his side not this time counted
out by theis Rozier
[Music]
two rows here look at Tatum there's the
cut there's two Hammer as Tatum throws
it down
great pass Rozier great finish short
class three to shoot a trunk on hurts
two scores to beat the clock basket time
the Lakers going up against a real put
decentering
Jimmy Butler but made it look so easy
give up on the play kept it alive
[Music]
[Applause]
easy then tears the great expedition
LeBron forces Israel
the corner to shoot Ottoman with
granted touch it down baby oh how about
that bass oh my goodness Wow how about
that defensive play
an excellent job of going straight up I
don't know why the fans are going out
with us Tyson Chandler in with
caldwell-pope
Caleb back down Ingram Ingram for three
that's good as the shot clock expires
back in action bad turnover Tatum's
drives and finishes Taylor with a slam
and it's back up to 20 feed pair of the
fourth quarter the line six to shoot
no rope he is gonna fall back at store
now he peaked at this clock on the other
end of the floor when I threw it to him
when he had his back to the basket at
the free-throw line
[Applause]
five on the shot clock that Drummond
Donald Tatum takes it makes it a
sidestep between the legs low shot clock
four seconds
there's the sidestep to create the space
there's that sweet jumper holiday Veta
cutting Davis broken up by James
Rondo flops Ingram throws it down
good job by immediately to get back
defensively datum takes it anyway
oh geez so it only takes one for him to
get hot three in a row then he takes it
off the bounce goes right steps back
bottom shot clock down to four here's
Ingram gotta put it up and beats the
shot clock with a Smith field goal this
is under duress of that shot clock drew
is an excellent defender tries to make
the right play close the space but how
about that getting that off win to make
the right play Tatum step back three oh
he took I like second do that for the
night forget about what's going on at
the other a same thing
rushing one the Lakers down to David
jumps out our tato
[Music]
I'll just knock down three and get a
chance for four-point play as
between the legs look at the step back
there's the head nothing but bottom
leave it back for dont't watched it back
gets it back gets doubled there's that
length of it Grove again celery's
[Music]
[Applause]
we could serve it at don't care Ingram
trying to shake O'Neill two seconds left
Ingram puts it up and gets it with 2/10
of a second remaining 50 yards I take
Marcus smart Celtics have numbers it's a
three on one the potato hate to go in
the period because JCP know the clock is
branded sure does he's looked at it
there he is he bounces off the defender
and scores
[Applause]
forces trying to void the contract oh
good follow
[Music]
tied up zoo box for to shoot back to
Ingram turnaround jumper it's good
top chakra bedroom that is outstanding
defense by the rock looking at him and I
see the potential already he rose under
that body it's crazy
I said yes attention ladies
this is body tight Eyez finds Ingram
again shot clock at two he's got to put
it up Ingram drives just gets it off the
time that he knocks it down
[Applause]
changes going to them that's an
excellent defense
[Music]
[Applause]
buzzer bye
fifteen turn over there 25 points off
there so it's just this hand thick take
care of that again they got it that time
you citizens ball lock him in his back
pediment Ingram looking looking gets it
inside
Irving falling away won't go rebound
tatum tato follows it up puts it in
cataluña the Sixers beat the Celtics for
the first time this season not a force
the switch don't get it on they're able
to stay at home on a bet that ties it be
free
hi twins have done that Morris gets
double-teamed kicks it out they find the
open man in the corner it's Tatum the
two and Shawn he's serious patience that
clock is running down little escape
triple Ron those sneaks inside gets it
to Ingram shot clock winding down angle
Matz to throw it up and gets it a go
Clarkson again penetrating double-team
in the baseline taters picks off the
pass cancer they had good that is smart
back to Tatum Figueroa of the truth
jumper strong that 23 point first
quarter by Kuzma were the most by 76 to
opponent this season LeBron on the LOB
and Ingram at the other end of it yeah
by the end of the game he'll probably
have his 25 or 26 Aegis look Tatum on
the attack Tatum to the basket a
blocking foul count and one in the
restricted area
you got to see it right here closer than
I thought
yeah no right heel was in the heel was
on there before year-old Lakers 28 28
same play at the beginning of the game
that dick work to Kuzma it works with
ain't grow the down though guys let him
find a seat my goodness
Antietam exposed off the baseline reek
picks up number one beautiful quick loo
here my Tatum to go baseline it's no
rotation weak side for the Pacers
[Applause]
the double to Nevada
and here take them again look at all the
blue jerseys around them just finds a
wide open Gordon hey work for the
Anthony Davis controversy have played
their best basketball when he's been on
the bench for not one loose ball with
the shot clock at two it ends up in the
hands of Ingram and he slams it in
French Turner is on the go
[Applause]
[Music]
that's happened for the last minute for
the patient's you've got a foul Haworth
there if you're Cory Joseph 1814
Milwaukee in front gentle tea with six
points to this first Jack vada cordia's
feed from Ingram vendor in Middleton and
then a postman
Boston leading by 10 here Satyam with a
quick post up mismatch and knocker
samples a depth of Milwaukee two to
shoot Ingram's gonna have to he does
[Applause]
on the shocked by Middleton but to cash
in on the lay up he has to know that
help is coming
[Applause]
so wait like right there I thought that
could have been a foul there they don't
whistle that and rightly show me what's
up you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content